now what i remember about you though is
you always had this
i don't want to say swagger but you
always were confident you always seemed
really confident
and poker no in life
in life you felt i felt like ken
just
is exudes this confidence now what i
want to know is it's something that you
always had like if we rewind the clock
back to grade school in high school you
were a confident kid no you weren't no i
mean i think i had to uh well i don't i
don't
i don't know if i'm
i don't see myself as super confident
now
really um
but i do
i guess there is a certain part of
you know uh being in this town where you
have to pretend to be confident in order
to survive don't let them see a weakness
you know what i mean and so
maybe there's a little bit of a
confident persona or maybe maybe it is
part of who i am
um but i
i like to uh
i think the best way to
professionally get
jobs is i mean the only way is to be
confident right i mean when you go on
audition for something as soon as you
start second guessing yourself the
audition is dead or the interview is
dead or the meeting is dead
so
i've i turned a corner on that when
well
i was confident
when i was in the state and when we were
doing the state and mtv out of college
because i was with all my buddies and we
all
um you all helped each other out we all
helped each other out it was a safe
place so i i was around that and then i
came out here and was introduced to this
town in a
in a
not as friendly way i i replaced
somebody on a tv show and i worked with
some people
and um it was not
a pleasant experience and i lost my
identity
and you lost your identity that's a
strong phrase i lost who i was or how i
could
uh
uh survive in certain situations
professionally and i can i couldn't
figure out how to navigate
the
uh
work environment
and i suffered because of it it was it
was bad
and then when that ended oh no in the
middle of that in the middle of that
show i
got my
for lack of a better word you know
phrase i got my balls back and i
i wanted to say something about balls
and it was something i saw on tick tock
where people like somebody's like
talking about balls and like women or
women women
they're everybody talks about like
calling somebody a vagina or a [ __ ]
and they're like that's a sign of
weakness whereas like a vagina and a
[ __ ] like
uh
so strong and like give life and do you
know like it couldn't be like
the opposite of
the you know calling somebody that and
then balls when you you say people have
balls
uh
says you know like that they're tough
but if you tap somebody's balls
they're the most fragile that's so true
it's such a it's a you touch
the testicle yeah you're done clearly
men have come up with those two you know
definitions of those two ways of using
that as slang anyway um
so i got my i got my uh my my power back
but i want to know like that's to say
something like you lost your balls
or your vagina and then you got it back
yeah now the interesting part to me is
how the hell you got it back like what
what did you do to get it back well i uh
i
i mean the truth is is i
got to a point where i couldn't i
couldn't deal with it anymore i couldn't
deal with like the chaos of like trying
to figure out how to
navigate uh without using the tools that
i knew i had
and i forgot that i had those tools for
a while and i'm like oh no
live or die by the tools that you have
um
and
at least then you go down
knowing that
you were true to yourself
you